こんにちは ザディープダイブです
今回はですね
あなたからお預かりしたえーと令和7年8月21日付の板橋区の子ども家庭教育に関する
資料ですね
活動報告とか委員会の質疑応答記録とか まあ いろいろあります
これらを深く掘り下げていこうと思います
資料が多いだけに情報も本当豊富で 今回の私たちのミッションは
これらの文書から まあ 区がどんな課題に直面してて どう動こうとしているのか
その確信を探って あなたにとって重要だろうなっていうポイントを
こう明らかにすることです
では早速ですが まずは子どもたちの支援の現場から見ていきましょうか
えっとまず注目したいのは こども家庭総合支援センターの活動報告ですね
資料一です
令和6年度の相談件数 これ 年間で3700件を超えてるんですね
うん 多いですね
うん その中でも特にその虐待に関する相談が増えているようで
援助課が受けた相談のうち
半数以上700件近くが心理的虐待に関するものだということです
ええ この心理的虐待の相談件数がこう突出して多いというのは
あの見過ごせない点ですよね
まあ もちろん相談が増えた背景には 問題への認識が広まったとか あるいはまあ
相談しやすくなったっていう側面もあるのかもしれませんが ただ
それでもこれだけ多くの声が上がっているということはですね
家庭内で見えにくいストレスとか
困難が確実に増えている可能性を示唆しているんじゃないかと
なるほど 言葉の暴力とか無視とか 子どもの前での夫婦喧嘩なんかも含まれますから
範囲は広いですし これが今の子どもたちを取り巻くまあ一
その現実なんでしょうね
うーん 深刻ですね
それに連動するように 子どもたちを一時的に保護する件数も増えているそうですね
令和6年度は311件で えっと前の年から1.2倍ですか
ええ 1.2倍です
区の施設だけでは足りなくて
里親さんとか乳児院とか外部にお願いするケースも結構あるんですね
96件はい状況もあるみたいで
なんかこう現場はかなり逼迫している感じですかねえ
そうなんです
一方で その長期的に家庭での養育が難しい子どもたち
まあ 社会的養護が必要な子という言い方をしますが
この子たちを里親さんに託すっていう動きは
まだこう十分に進んでいないという現状がありますね
ああ そうなんですね
対象の子どもさんが約200人いる中で 里親委託は24件
登録している里親家庭は50以上あるのにです
うーん やはりマッチングの難しさとか
まあ 里親さんのなり手不足 それからサポート体制
こういう根深い課題があるようです
区もですね
里親制度を知ってもらうための活動 アウトリーチって言いますけど
それとか一時保護の受け入れを通じて経験を積んでもらうとか
まあ工夫はしているようですが
どうすれば子どもたちにとって最善の環境である家庭的な用語をもっと広げられるのか
これは本当に大きなと
だと思います
うーん 地域全体での見守りという点ではどうでしょう
要保護児童対策地域協議会通称容体協ですか
これの活動報告もありますね
はい 学校とか保育園とか約400か所を回って 気になる子の情報を共有したり
支援の方針を確認したりしていると 早期発見のためにチェックリストを使うとか
具体的な助言をするみたいな地味な活動がやっぱり重要
なんですね まさにそれに加えて NPOとか
そういう民間団体との連携も模索されていますね
はい 例えばかっこお届け便
これは食料なんかを必要としている家庭に届ける事業で
民生委員さんとか子ども食堂とかが協力している昨年度は85世帯
160人以上の子どもたちが利用したそうです
あ 訂正後の数字ですね これへーこうした地域のさまざまな主体が関わることで
よりきめ細やかな支援が可能になると
ただ あの議事録からは支援を届けやすくすることと
相談に来る親子のプライバシーを守ること このバランスの難しさっていう声
聞こえてきますね
ああ なるほど それは難しいですねえ
難しいかじ取りが求められ
ています
新しい取り組みとしては こども家庭センター機能の強化
つまり妊娠期から切れ目なく相談に乗れる体制作り
それから後は産後ドゥーラーの活用支援も始まっているんですね
ええ これ産後のお母さんを専門的に支える人のことですよね
そうで そうです
でも これも何か利用したくても予約が取りにくいとか 特に急ぎの場合とか
人気の時間帯は難しい なんていう課題も出ているみたいですね
ええ
利用料の負担軽減とか
あとはもっと多くの人にこういう支援があるんだよって知ってもらう
その必要性が議論されていますね
面白いなと思ったのは 家が片付いていないから
人に来てもらうのはちょっとっていう
そういう心理的なハードルもあるっていう指摘があったことですね
ああ 分かりますね それこれは もしかしたら支援を受けること自体が
まだちょっと特別なことっていう意識があるのかもしれない
子育てのしんどさをもっと気軽に助けてって言えるような
そういう空気作りも実は大事なのかもしれないですね
なるほど
いや 子育てを取り巻く課題って
本当に多様なんだなっていうのがよく分かりますね
さて ちょっと視点を変えて 次は教育の分野を見ていきましょうか
はい 教育委員会の動き資料二ですね
これもいろいろありますが 特に大きな変化と言えそうなのが
中学の部活動の地域以降 これが資料三 それと春休みの日程変更資料六
この辺りでしょうか
そうですね
えー まず部活動の地域移行ですが これはあの教員の働き方改革っていう側面と
あとは少子化が進む中で
子どもたちのスポーツとか文化活動の機会をどう持続的に確保していくかっていう
まあ 2つの大きな目的がありますね
ふむふむ 2028年度までの3年間で段階的に進める計画
板橋区立中学校部活動地域移行実施計画2028
これをこれから策定するという方針です
国の動きとも連動していますね
ただ
議事録を読むとですね
単に先生の負担を減らすって
それだけじゃないだろうと移行する先の地域の指導者の方に
どうやってその教育的な目的意識これを共有してもらうのか
生徒の成長って 具体的に何を指すのかみたいな
結構根本的な問いかけもありましたね
ええ 最近 ほら 高校野球でも指導者のあり方が問われるケースがありましたけど
単に技術を教えるだけじゃない
その人間的な成長の部分をどう担保するのかっていうのは 確かに重要ですよね
まさにそこが確信ですね
区の説明では あくまで生徒の成長機会の確保が第一であって
そのために教員の負担を減らして 結果的に教育の質を上げるっていう まあ
両輪で考えているという説明のようです
なるほど 指導者の質については
スポーツマンシップとかハラスメント防止の意識とか
そういうのを採用時に確認するとはしていますが 学校という悪組みが外れた時に
その理念をどう浸透させていくのかっていうのは
これから具体的に詰めていく必要がありそうです
まあ 大局的に見れば これまで学校が担ってきた青年育成の役割の一部が
地域社会へと移っていくという大きな転換点と言えるでしょうね
保護者とか生徒からすると もっと切実な問題もありますよね
うちの子が入る部活はいつどう変わるの
みたいな具体的な情報が早く欲しいという声
えー それはそうでしょうね
これは中学校選びにも影響しますからね
うん 実際に野球部で先行して始まった地域クラブ化では
開始時期がちょっと急だったんじゃないかっていう意見もあったみたいです
この秋以降にアンケート調査をして 関係者の声を聞く予定だそうですけど
もう1つの大きな変更点が春休みの延長ですね
資料六これは令和8年度から今より2日間 長くなって4月7日までになるほう
目的はですね 先生たちが新年度の準備をする時間を暦に関係なく
しっかり5日間確保するため出す
そうです
なるほど 先生たちの準備時間を確保するためなんですね
ええ これによって入学式とか始業式の日程も変わるんですね
小中学校は2日後ろ倒しそうなんです
授業時間が減るんじゃないかっていう心配もありそうですけど
その影響は小さいと見込んでいるようです
まあ これも働き
き方改革の一環と言えそうで
すね次は子どもたちが日々過ごす学校の建物
その環境と安全について見ていきましょう
資料4を見ると 区内の学校施設の改築とか
改修が計画的に進められているのが分かりますね
はい
上橋第一中学校とか志村小学校第四中なんかが今進んでいるか
これから着工予定とこれから計画される学校木原小学校板橋 第一中 板橋
第五中なんかは 単に建て替えるだけじゃなくて 地域の他の施設
例えば駅周辺の活性化とか
文化会館とかと連携していくことも考えているみたいですね
これは興味深い視点ですね
単なる老朽化対策にとどまらないで
学校を確認した地域づくりみたいな発想が見えますよね
ええ 特に板橋第一中 第五 中東文化会館グリーンホールとの連携なんかは
学校と地域のリソースをどうつなげていくかという まあ
未来への投資とも言えそうです
一方で 具体的な事例として 板橋 第六小学校の増改築 これも資料四にありますが
これを見るとその難しさも浮かび上がってきますね
ああいた
第六章ええ近くに
大規模マンションができて教室が足りなくなるという
まあ 喫緊の課題に対応するためなんですが
限定的な敷地の中で今の校舎を使いながら段階的に工事を進めて
最終的な完成は令和15年の目標とかなり長期にわたる計画
です
10年以上かかるんです
ねそうなんです
地域の人の利用も考えながら法的な制約もある中で
というのはかなりなんていうかパズルのような作業で
ですよね
そして 学校の安全という点で避けては通れないのがいじめの問題です
資料五では 2件の重大事態についての調査結果が報告されています
これは非常に重い内容なので 慎重に事実を客観的にお伝えしたいと思います
ええ
まず事案一致についてですね これは小学校1年生から5年生にかけて
複数の児童から継続的にいじめを受けたとされるケースです
調査の結果 申告された28件のうち
24件が法律上のいじめに該当すると認定されました
24件
ええ 調査報告書とか質疑応答で特に問題視されているのは
学校側の対応の遅れですね
いじめがあったかもしれないというまずその認知
それをきちんと記録して関係者で共有すること そして初期段階での適切な対応
これらに不備があったと指摘されています
うーん 転校をきっかけに調査が始まったという経緯とか
調査自体にも約2年かかったという点も自体の複雑さを物語っていますね
具体的な再発防止策も挙げられていますね
いじめの定義を正しく理解するとか 記録のフォーマットを統一して 確実に共有する
子どもからの話の聞き方を改善する 関係者への情報共有を適切に行う 法令や
ガイドラインの理解を徹底するなどなど 多岐にわたりますね
ええ さまざまな対策が並んでいますが
あのー質疑応答での議論で重要だと感じたのは
個々の先生の頑張りに頼るんじゃなくて
学校全体としての仕組みで対応できるようにしなきゃ意味がないという指摘ですね
あー 仕組みか
そうです
例えば 報告とか共有のワークフローをちゃんと確立するとか
あるいはAIみたいな技術も活用して 記録の負担を減らしつつ
確実に情報を残すとか そういう具体的な仕組み作りと
それが本当に現場で機能するかどうか
その実効性の担保が今後の大きな課題でしょうね
あと付け加えると
加害者とされる側から十分に話を聞けなかったケースもあったようで
これも対応の難しさを示している点だと
思います
もう1つの事案二については 調査は終わったけれども
被害を受けたお子さんと保護者の意向で 結果は公表しないということですね
ええ
プライバシーへの配慮がなされた
ということです
さて 最後にですね
委員会の質疑応答資料8からちょっと具体的な原画の困りごとが見える事例を1つ紹介
させてください
等身児童館が週末に一時的に閉まらざるを得なかったという話です
はい
原因は排水設備の不具合で 下の階の保育園に水漏れしてしまったと ああ
それは大変ですねええ
それで週末は運営を委託している業者さんが入っていて
保育園の洗濯機とかも使えない状況になってしまって
衛生管理上の問題から閉館せざるを得なかったということらしいんです
うん これは日常的な施設の維持管理っていう
まー 地味な作業がいかに大切かということと
それが滞ってしまうと地域住民が必要とするサービス
特にほら 暑い日の避難場所としての児童館の役割とか
そういうのに直接影響が出てしまうということを示す
まあ 象徴的な事例かもしれませんね
そうですね 議員さんからは土曜日だけでも何とか開けられなかったのか
という意見も出ていましたけど やはり安全とか衛生を確保しながら
サービスを続けることの現実的な難しさが ここには現われているように思います
さて
ここまで 児童福祉教育改革 学校環境と安全 そして現場の具体的な課題まで
本当に多岐にわたる資料を見てきました
虐待への対応強化とか 里親支援 部活動の地域移行 学校の建て替え
いじめへの組織的対応板原区がさまざまな課題にこう継続的に取り組んでいる様子が
うかがえますよね
そうですね
これらの報告全体を通して見えてくるのは まあ 少子高齢化とか働き方の変化
子どもたちの安全 施設の老朽化といった 現代の自治体が
どこも共通して抱えるような複雑な課題に対して
板橋区が具体的に向き合って対策を打とうとしている その姿だと思います
ええ ただ同時に 理想通りにはいかない現場の難しさというのも感じますね
例えば 一時保護所の定員の問題とか 里親のマッチングの難しさ
地域以外での価値観の共有 いじめ対応での情報連携の壁施設の維持管理の現実
そういった実践面での苦労とか 課題も資料の行間からこう透けて見えてくる
気がします
心理的虐待のように見えにくい問題の深刻化 それから
地域移行を支える指導者の確保 先生達の負担の問題
学校施設の更新と地域連携の複雑さ いじめ対応の仕組み化の難しさ
何かこれらの課題ってそれぞれ独立しているようでいて
実は根っこの部分で繋がっている そういう部分もあるのかもしれないですね
ええ そう思います
そこで最後にあなたに考えてみてほしい問いがあります
これらの報告書が示すさまざまな取り組みとか計画 それらを踏まえた上でですね
更に一歩進んで 板橋区の子ども達と家庭を本当に支える環境を築く為には
現在の計画以上に私達地域社会全体として
どのような協力とか連携の形があり得るんでしょうか
分野横断的なもっと積極的なかかわり 城はどこにあると考えますか